[Music]
foreign
it's also one of the world's biggest
producers and users of coal the dirtiest
fossil fuel and the single largest
contributor to climate change
we are at the devra coal mines one of
the largest coal mines in the world in
the Indian state of chattisgarh
we are seeing Vehicles move around us
carrying this coal to different power
plants to meet the rising electricity
demand caused by the rising Heat
and this coal is being taken out by
workers who are braving this 40 degrees
Centigrade plus Heat
to make sure that the power plants do
not run out of this precious fuel
among them is 37 year old Ravi Bera who
has been working here since 2011.
foreign
a changing climate has made extreme heat
30 times more likely in India people who
work outside like rabi sometimes in your
life-threatening temperatures
the World Bank estimates up to 75
percent of India's Workforce is
vulnerable to the effects of high heat
and humidity
is available
[Music]
the high demand often overwhelms the
nation's Supply infrastructure and
results in widespread blackouts
the lack of access to Safe Drinking
Water especially in rural areas also
increases the risks of dehydration in
this Village some people walk more than
half a mile round trip to get water
[Music]
um
prime minister Narendra modi's
government has raised its targets for
clean energy capacity but they have also
pushed back against efforts to get rid
of cold use entirely
is
[Music]
though India has made climate finance
and green development a priority it's
not getting rid of cold use anytime soon
[Music]
foreign